gunter gabriel ist wieder da mit einem
neuen ungewöhnlichen album sohn aus dem
volk wieder entdeckt wurde er für dieses
projekt ausgerechnet auf einem autohof
der geiselwinder raststätte an der a 3
das berichtet er in der online talkshow
clixoom de
immer wenn ich von hamburg nach münchen
fahren mit meinem auto halte ich da
übernachtet da in dem hotel inzwischen
und sitzt damit jungs am stammtisch ist
so mein zweites zuhause und für eine
morgens frühstück kommt ein typ auf mit
zu sein junger banker wie du ungefähr
und sagen du bist der held meiner jugend
und blablabla denke daher diese übliche
quatsch ja und
ich habe da eine idee ersten mal ich
habe das richtig war dollars und hier
ist meine karte ich habe gedacht na ja
doch geht erzählt erzählt erzählen das
übliche und dann hat ja aber nicht nur
noch gelassen hat nicht locker gelassen
so kam es dass wir uns trafen und er hat
die idee macht ihr mal zeigt doch mal
die andere seite von dir du bist doch
nicht immer der proll oder mann du
kannst du noch ein bisschen mehr als nur
über über diese chor zu singen und das
macht er auf dem album er selbst ist von
dem ergebnis beeindruckt dieses dieser
song ich bin ja nichts ist phänomenal
mir geglückt weil es weil es halt wo ich
stehe trotzdem ist er unzufrieden
ich habe keine zeit mir richtig für mich
selbst mal nicht und das ist immer
bedrohlich